hello hello kr welcome for the how are
you good good thanks for coming this is
Jim Norton I'm Sam Roberts and that is
rich
Voss he put his hat on for you yeah
anything I own could be sold but I did
steal I know I'm just saying that you
know you can mean the middle now do you
really like it had are you just being
polite
no I love the Hat you like men in hats
are only certain faces for a hat well I
also wonder if do you like the hat or do
you like him wearing the hat like you
could like the Hat as its own thing
looks good the picture looks good okay I
say okay yeah okay I don't think he
looks a little silly in a white hat
no it's just summer a little like it's
not exactly a resort town
you know I December Chepo and here's I
had seven of these hats
I picked the white one today oh yeah a
hat company oh nice Kohana Hat Company
le Bailly give you here belly nice hats
it's cheap it did she had it's already
going down seven you know at $60 about
$40 it's a $30 hat no it's it's cheap
hats are you out of your crazy mind look
him up online they're not they're not
good we don't Carol you beans ice it's
not a good ass yeah I mean if you have
seven of the same at odds are you got a
deal on no no I buy them at different
times I got winter I got different
colors to match different clothing you
know silly right
it's it's a little silly know why you
don't have to panic that you're gonna
lose your head but it is it back up back
up
these are my six back of hat how many
pairs of sneakers you have Sam
I collect sneakers I collect hat should
give yah yah yah yah these are my
sneakers today tomorrow will be
something different yeah I got colorful
socks on match or any no my sneakers and
socks do not do look at this a big
advantage to that
see that how that matches the blue in
the Hat why do you like his blue
childish sneakers so you don't like him
do you
you know what's ironic about those
anchors he'll be 60 next week ya know
very colorful sneaker look
yes cheesy right I like me a nice white
or black pair of sneakers or a smart
shoe yes my vegetarian Doc Martens I see
you like Doc Martens I enjoy Doc Martens
I'm wearing my Reggie Jane Doc Martens
what a vegetarian duck Lawrence Antonio
not made salmon
yeah I didn't know that without bein
vegetarian after that mean yes all we
don't know but I mean is there a brand
of doctor to call vegetarians are they
always right
no they're not all vision but I'll tell
you the big plus of the vegetarian
beside the fact that nobody died to be
on your shoe is such a very light
compared to leather ok maybe I will look
at look em up because I'm very fat feet
out on top of the night cigar minds but
they are the vegetarian version but they
can be a little heavy Doc Martens well
not these ones I just oh no no no no no
try please pay attention
no I don't want to start a thing believe
me I'll look it up I'll look at it
prepare that we've already had two
things in the three minutes that is true
yeah that is tremendous understandings
rich and I are fighting you and Carol
are fighting things are not good here
things are not good
there's so much to talk to you about I
would love to ask you but well you're in
one of my favorite you're in my favorite
sitcom of all time and you're in my one
of my favorite films of all time Dog Day
Afternoon oh yeah I want to talk about
that I see you guys I mean you guys like
very few people got to work with John
Cazale well I am so lucky because I got
to work with John a lot I because I was
also working with him in a play called
dog day after not not that like as a
resistible rise of our jury without
Pacino and John and I work together a
lot so that we got to do this play at
the Public Theater and in Boston so um
he was a dear and incredible
friend and as we all know is a genius
yeah and uh you stayed in touch with him
after you did that tell him enough
always and you thought that he got sick
how long did you know he was sick for
before he passed away
[Music]
Wow Wow yeah because they said that they
it was amazing the documentary that they
did the deer hunter means they shot in a
certain order because they knew that he
was not well which I thought was pretty
amazing that everybody knew and they
still got the film done that's true what
was it that made him you know brilliant
like what was the quality that you could
isolate yeah thank separated him from
some other actors I'm incapable of doing
a second of dishonest work he just was a
hundred percent there all the time never
in fact I something that was so brave
that it did is when you do a movie or a
play you generally do a reading of it
first you read the whole script out loud
and it's almost impossible not to try
and be the best kid in the class at the
reason you know you're trying to you you
want everybody go up to you at the end
and say oh my god you really good yeah
so John as I said incapable of being
dishonest ever just would sit there and
just not act he just wouldn't put if
something wasn't there for him he
wouldn't fake it he wouldn't push
anything and that was really scary to do
because people are really trying to get
a lot of approval close readings it's
just the human thing to do but John
would be he was so pure as an artist he
was so pure and so wasn't about approval
for him he didn't have that actor I
think what was about discovering what
was there and being honest and
discovering what what was
what's the kid so you just read it
through plain like just like read it
like you're reading a book out loud not
trying to be like he wasn't like going
out of his way to bore people saying
like that he just was in other words
okay so you're reading you're doing a
reading and say 70% of it you're feeling
in touch with the words and what's
happening in the scene it says or say
50% or whatever then most of us will
push the part that we're not sure we
would try and live up to what we think
the director and the writer are hoping
to get as an end result you know I mean
I try not to do that but like I say it's
almost impossible you do on that right
had some praise you know so we we push
the stuff that were not able to get to
sometimes and say if you had to cry or
laugh or whatever I knew or just or yell
or whatever and John just wouldn't push
anything if it was there for him it
would be there and if it wasn't that
wouldn't be like the high point of the
reading you know but it actually kind of
was the high point for me because he
just never made an actor that's quite
that honest you know yeah do actors like
say we talked about this for comics you
know say a bunch of actors were sent out
hanging out having dinner discussing
good actors you know what they who they
considered actors would you put more
emphasis on what actors think of other
actors or fans think of actors well I I
don't I don't think it's an either/or is
we try to what I said tell me a question
I know we did it guys just would comic
sees it Carol can I tell you what just
happened why because it's a bizarre
question it is a question and you have a
stunned that somebody had some question
yeah it's to make my for the real time
the reason he asked you that question I
said what I'm saying already okay yeah
number three what's this Jim and I were
both annoyed that he asked you that
question because he only asked you that
question he hoping that you would agree
with
he said two hours ago so then you could
go see I told you I tried to tell you
guys yeah which is like that's not why
you're in here is that what happened
right okay we have stayed a selfish
she's very sorry I'm sorry I made it
tense no reason at once you give her
that no no me that the guy need to I'll
give you a hundred bucks if you take his
hat off in summer right now give me a
hug give me a hundred bucks I'll step on
you is it difficult right so after you
have that experience yeah does it become
more difficult for you to work with
actors that maybe not are that's great
of course like as you can see like you
can be that good why are you not
striving to be well it's not a cut I
don't think it's a question of striving
you know it's a sensibility and
sensitivity empathy and you know it's
it's in your heart and mind you know and
so if you've had good teachers hopefully
they will help you get toward that state
but if you don't have you know not
everybody has done because enemies
incredible heart and mind you know right
no matter how much they strive so
actually they'll be almost the opposite
you can't really strive to be the right
way this valley I got honest like you
can't true you have to just be right you
have to remind yourself to just try and
stay like they say which is I'm just
repeating a cliche in the moment guys
also not to be reaching a header yeah
is it Thank You Sally I'm insane kids al
for 40 years some people say kids now
some people say to them okay so I'm not
a complete fool and you were also in
taxi and you get to work all that Andy
Kaufman who I never met so what was he
like to work with because you hear a
very mixed story some people loves
working with him and some people didn't
like we wasn't 20 yeah um I loved
working with him even though we had a
completely different approach to the
work because I come from
the theater and in the theater rehearsal
is everything right you just rehearse
until you drop dead practically and then
it's probably hot enough anyway and any
you know used to explain to me that that
was bad for his process rehearsing was
no good for him because he you know was
a performance artist I guess people call
him stand up or comedian but he was
definitely a performance artist and he
did not like to be set in anything he
liked to be spontaneous and um so how he
has this a discussion every week that we
worked together because they had a fake
Andy for for three and a half of the
five days of the rehearsal week they had
a fake Andy that all had four guys there
was Jennifer Danica round was a carpet
of cardboard and their string around his
neck and said Andy and he would be you
know he would talk for scenes with you
and do this and then Andy would come in
the day of the performance and I would
be mad because I didn't get the rears
with my real Andy and Andy would be
apologetic but explain to me how he
couldn't he just couldn't and he had it
in his contract and I was a late comer
you know but um he could do that and I
was nervous about not working with him
enough and then we'd have this
discussion and we would be honest with
each other and by the time we finished
our discussion every week we would be
together you know we would we would have
a closeness because we just come from
this sort of a married couples kind of
discussions so he wasn't being difficult
he really was that way no he wasn't
being difficult it was in his contract
he felt that that's the way you work the
best I don't know if that's true of most
people in comedy or whatever but that
was true for him and he he was protected
protecting him his more
did that frustrates the other cast
members that like he didn't have to work
for weeks while everybody else did like
that he got special treatment I don't
know how they felt about it we really
discussed is every every like portrayal
I feel like every behind-the-scenes
portrayal of taxi feels like there's a
lot of hostility towards andis from the
rest of the cast yeah that's right
feeling you see that in all the sort of
documentaries that come out I feel like
in the movie in the man on the moon
movie it seemed like you know most of
the cast was fed up with with Andy's
antics and the Tony Clifton stuff and I
think it was difficult in the sense that
because he was such a brilliant
performance artist you sort of never
knew where you were and that that was a
little difficult for people such as when
he did the Jerry Lawler thing and he you
know hurt his neck and he went to the
hospital and then when it came back to
work he was wearing the brace and
everything and notice and then Danny
Danny slowed down the filming and
figured out that hey you know the thing
was very pliable and that it was all
probably a setup she's working you guys
he was working well he was working he
was working not just say that Eva and um
and people had sent him flowers and
magazines the food and all that stuff
and so then I think maybe some people
felt annoyed that we didn't get special
that's that's what we didn't get we
didn't get special treat he didn't let
you know hey like I'm okay it was good
but you can I mean you can't see because
you don't know but that is critical as
critical to who you as as an artist he
never ever winked at anybody never you
know he he never said yeah but not
really he never said that he just put it
out there and it was up to you if you
believed him or didn't believe him and
there was no compromising as pie boy was
the first one was the first time you had
to meet deal with Tony Clifton
oh I you know I I didn't really work
with Tony Clifton did right does anybody
remember my life because I don't I'm not
sure if I I must have a little bit but I
was not for instance I was not there
when Tony Clifton got fired for one
thing then this was a big scandal at the
show that that that he actually got
himself fired use um he came in with
hookers and alcohol and smoking and and
he wouldn't he was laid all the time and
II by the way was not like right he was
very responsible his work ethic was
strong it was just specific you know
right my Tony didn't have quite the same
word and he just made it so hard on
everybody that they the producers fired
they fired Andy or they said no more
Tony know what time they fired Tony hit
Tony got thrown off the lot
yeah Tony got Joe knows a lot so crazy
hey commit to it so strongly - yeah and
it's um yeah it's really yes I mean he
had so many secrets you know and and and
that's the key what you just said he
committed to everything I percent I
would like to revisit the like taxi set
and everything when you guys did man on
the moon because they brought most of
the cast right again it was very
emotional and peculiar because just said
was our it was like exactly artists Edna
Chris Danny was one of the producers of
the movie as well as playing George his
man and Angie's manager and so he knew
he got it right right now I realize of
course once things true and right so it
was very emotional very weird and then
seeing you know Jim be sort of Jim but
sort of Andy and sort of Tony and it was
very confusing yeah
me how was Jim and Jim Carrey is nightly
yeah yeah I thought it was little how
about as Eddie Carlton would you think
his performance yeah I thought I thought
it was lovely I am I may be the one
thing I saw it could have been there a
little more and it's not a performance
thing is that Andy said the sweetness to
him that was just unbelievable and I
don't think they of course sweetness
does not a movie make you know the road
right dates you know get more involved
with some of the more bizarre things and
yeah and you were in when a stranger
calls my tune
somebody's calling about that on the
phone don't answer it is what I am Joel
what did you want to say he wants to
take something to Carol hello Joan
Wisconsin have you checked the children
I knew this already do not thank you so
she they warned you thank you Jim that
is one of the more iconic and horrifying
things in the film ever yeah horrible oh
that was really did you know when you
when you tell me something it's PI hard
to understand how terrifying it is until
you finally see it removed were you able
to tell when you're doing it um I read
it so I'm just you know French what's it
read anyway um it's not as terrifying
when you're shooting because you have
100 people around you but I got a sense
of the suspense of it the way it was
shot you know like a long slow shot of
from the feet up to my face for how you
take the children by the time you get to
the face or something you're ready to
scream even though nothing's happened
you know it was that pace of the
suspenseful piece of shooting too and
and then when they told you the calls
coming from in the house that it's just
terrifying
it's awful and and you know they say
that it came from you know there's
folklore that things like that have
happened
one two babysitters I don't know if
that's true or not true but I sure
wouldn't want to be a babysitter after
seeing that movie no way you have a
sorry Tara no go ahead
who is the shadow of the door do you
remember who they used to play the
shadow the guy walks in the door there
was a guy shadow of the door opening oh
you don't know if I just some producer
appear thank you damn pardon I don't
recall you have any idea when when the
movies you're working on are going to
last forever like I feel like
specifically The Princess Bride and
Scrooged our movies that like people see
them when they were a kid and just carry
them with them forever wonderful yes
it's kind of amazing what was the two
things that they have in common actually
is that whole fairy tale aspect and I
must say when you're shooting a movie
that's a fairy tale it's so it's so
special because the art director and
everybody have and the costume designers
and everyone are all working toward it
sort of a hyper real or surreal
atmosphere and like the set of screws
was so beautiful with the snow and the
little buildings that were the Christmas
village and all that stuff and then on
Princess Bride my god you know the
little Hut and we had to wear contact
lenses that you could really see through
very well and the smoke in the costumes
and so you are you are feeling that
you're in a fairy tale which is for me I
love that feeling I don't think I
thought well this will last forever
because you just never know when
something's cut together with it I want
it right right but they fit those two
movies felt very special in the process
did you meet Andre the Giant yet to fly
I mean that is special in and of itself
yeah Oh course I meant unto you I was
Andre another of the sweetest people on
the earth but just gently as they say
again his gentle giant very very
sneak down legendary stories about how
much you like to drink well there are
some of those stories I was not I did
not find him in the lobby of the hotel
and the floor which somebody did I guess
oh and there on that shooter that movie
that daytime in the lobby on the floor I
think something like that I mean I've
only read that same as you like to enjoy
a cocktail aren't you yeah I hear I've
heard he would put a few beers back he
would yeah what just like a hundred but
he was so big I mean he was big those
beers would go down fast I'm sure that
yeah he was a very big boy hopefully
they have to follow him in the bathroom
that's not good
exactly you don't see Andre coming out
of the porta potty